as the nation paused on friday to
remember the victims of the september
11th attacks the day
also served as a reminder of the many
young americans who were inspired to
enlist in the military
after those attacks among them was
sergeant major thomas patrick payne he
received the medal of honor from
president trump for his role
in freeing several captives being held
by isis
david martin reports sergeant major
patrick payne was a senior in high
school on 9 11. did you enlist because
of 9 11.
it was a call to service because of
because of that day
today he received the nation's highest
honor for his actions in a daring
hostage rescue mission in iraq
in 2015. as we're flying the target
the pilot passes that one minute call
back and that's when all joking stops
and that's when you make that transition
from soldier to warrior
the elite delta force stormed a compound
where isis was preparing to execute
their prisoners
you can hear the firefight going on
outside as they heard the prisoners out
of their cells
but more were trapped in a second
building which was on fire and in danger
of collapse
payne ran inside with a pair of bolt
cutters to cut the locks
so how many times did you go back in
that building i think a total four or
five times sir
four or five times on fire in danger of
collapsing
enemy fire it was our duty to bring
those men home
more than 70 hostages who were about to
die
instead freed from their cells and flown
to freedom
they realized they're being liberated
and that's when it hit me i'm like what
did we just do
one thing sergeant major patrick payne
did was bring
honor on the 911 generation david martin
cbs news the pentagon
what an incredible hero yeah and
especially something to reflect on
one day after the 9 11 anniversary it is
crazy to think that this is that 9 11
generation that that much time also has
gone by
and it's just amazing to see how
profoundly affected
that generation was by what happened and
you see as a result
tremendous bravery amazing courage and
what they've then done to help after
absolutely